rico chegando em casa vai logo correndo
para a televisão do jeito que ele tá da
escola com um tênis e tudo ele sobe em
cima do sofá e fica assistindo lá em
casa se subir com tênis em cima do sofá
morre o pobre chegando em casa é
diferente ele vem todo animado
[Música]
olha para trás tá tudo só o barro que
ele trouxe nos pés e pede menino não
sujando aquilo ali ele fica uma tatuagem
olha para a direita a mãe Terminando de
limpar a cozinha Porque é que o caba faz
aí voltando bem devagarzinho
[Música]
pega um pano
vai limpando com o pé e vai voltando
como se ele tivesse apagando a história
dele
[Música]
aí ele volta e finge que chegou de novo
é Mãe cheguei olha